-Our next guest is an
Emmy Award-winning
writer, comedian,
and actress you know from
her critically acclaimed series,
"Abbott Elementary."
The second season premieres
this Wednesday, September 21st,
on ABC.
Let's take a look.
-And no more bringing
my problems into school.
That was old
right-sided-part Janine.
I'm a fully formed adult,
and this year
is gonna be...different.
What the...
What in the world?
-Eagles! Go, Eagles!
[ Indistinct conversations ]
-Ava.
Why is a man cooking ribs
in my parking spot?
What is happening?
-It's game day, baby.
-It's Development Week.
-Here's a development.
You either got to park
on the street
or give me $50 for your spot.
I'm making extra money...
for the school.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Quinta Brunson,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hello, Quinta.
-Hi, Seth.
-You look fantastic.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
Hi, everybody.
Are they normally that nice?
-They're very --
No, they're only this nice
when people deserve it.
-Oh, my goodness.
-And congratulations.
Not only did you win an Emmy
for writing,
the show won
three Emmys overall.
Was it a -- was it a fun night?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was so fun.
You were there.
-I was.
-Part of the fun of the night
was getting to see you.
Always a treat.
But, you know, that was my
first time at the Emmys, period.
So to go as a nominee
and then have the opportunity
to not only win,
but have a castmate win
and the casting department --
just incredible.
-And your castmate --
I was lucky enough
to be onstage with Amy Poehler
when Sheryl Lee Ralph won.
And she not only
came onstage and gave
one of the greatest speeches
I've ever seen,
but she did seem
genuinely shocked in the moment.
You were at her table.
-I was at her table.
She was totally shocked.
Let me just say first,
you and Amy Poehler
could not have been better.
One of my favorite people.
Amy doesn't know it,
but she is one of my favorite --
She's one of my comedy moms.
And I was, like, "Oh, my God.
Wow, look at that.
It would be amazing if,
you know,
they said somebody from
'Abbot Elementary.'
Hmm."
And then I just talked to
Sheryl the week before,
and we had this beautiful talk
about how this is
a first-season show on
network TV with 13 episodes.
It's amazing to just be
nominated and be in the room.
And we had this beautiful talk
with each other of, like,
it didn't matter if we won.
And we didn't think that
we would win anything.
Especially Sheryl, who's like,
"You know, I'm just really happy
to be here and be nominated.
And you know what?
Hopefully,
the show will be around
and there's
plenty of time to win."
So she was really
in this place of just
pure joy with being nominated.
So when you guys called her
name, I looked at her,
and she -- I knew --
I know Sheryl very well.
Sheryl is very dramatic,
as you guys could see.
I know that,
in her brain, she said,
"This is a dream.
This is not real."
"I'm not going to get up."
And her whole body
went into shock.
And, you know,
everyone was like,
"Sheryl, they said your name."
But I know she was like,
"This is 'The Wizard of Oz.'"
Like, this -- I'm in a scene of
'The Wizard of Oz.'
Better wake up."
So I had to physically get up
and go shake her to say,
"This is real!"
and get her up.
And her husband's like,
"You won, you won, you won."
We're like, "Right there.
They said -- That's you, you,
Sheryl Lee Ralph."
She's like, "Me?"
"Sheryl Lee Ralph, you."
So, we get her up, and my
co-star Tyler James Williams --
I whispered -- I was like,
"You have to walk her
on the stage, because there's
a chance she might
turn back
thinking this is fake."
So Tyler walked her
on the stage.
And I think it was
once she was up there
that she really realized
that she had won.
And Sheryl comes into
the set singing.
Like, she comes in going...
♪ Good morning ♪
...every single morning.
So I think the first thing she
could do, out of joy,
was just sing,
and it was so beautiful.
-Well, it was so beautiful
and surprising,
because the first half
of the moment
was everything you've described,
someone who was in shock.
And, usually,
the second half of that
is someone who can't find
the words for the moment.
And, yet, she delivered a speech
that was as polished
and as finished
as anything you've ever seen.
-That's Sheryl.
-It felt like an one-act play.
It was beautiful.
-That is all day with
Sheryl Lee Ralph.
-Yeah.
-That is how she is.
So to me -- I could just cry now
because it was beautiful
seeing her be the most herself
in that moment, too.
There's something very pure
about her being
exactly who she is
while accepting that award
and making -- I'm getting teary.
But making a beautiful -- a
beautiful night for everybody.
-It was also --
It seems crazy to say this now,
but a network comedy getting
nominated is a throwback to,
you know,
a previous era of the Emmys.
We're not used to seeing that.
-Right.
-You wanted this to be
a network television show
at a time when
I feel a lot of creators
maybe are going
the other way.
-Yes. You know,
we've talked about this before,
but I love network television.
I love the accessibility of it.
People laugh at me
when I say this,
but it is something
people can watch in prison,
which is a huge demographic.
But it's not about that.
It's about accessibility.
-Yeah.
-It is about accessibility
and people being able to
watch network TV from anywhere.
And I feel like
my generation, Millennials,
started veering toward
the cable and streaming space,
and for one, I think they were
pushed away from network
for a while.
There was
just a misunderstanding
between the
previous generation and ours.
But after so many creators went
over and proved kind of, like,
the value of our stories
in network and streaming,
it feels like now
network kind of gets it,
and, thus, something like
"Abbott Elementary"
is able to be born.
And I'm happy
that it's on network TV.
I love that families
watch it together.
-Yeah, I mean, that's how my
family watched television,
obviously, growing up,
was that way.
And another thing
that happened is,
you had a successful
network television show,
and, again,
it's another throwback.
You did 13 your first season.
You're doing
a 22-episode season,
which now --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, that was the norm,
but that is an exception
to the rule now for comedy.
How has it been so far?
Obviously,
you're in the middle of it.
-I'm in the middle of it.
So, you know,
the producer in me is like,
"Why are you on
'Seth Meyers' right now?"
But then, also,
the producer in me is like,
"That's good marketing.
We need it for the show.
That's good publicity."
But then I'm like,
"Man, I really wish my actress
was on set so we didn't have to
rearrange her schedule
to do --"
So it's -- All of my brains
are having a fight at the same
time with 22 episodes.
But I will say,
I have such a supportive system
in my co-producers and
my writers and my crew and cast.
So, I think we are
doing a good job at it,
but 22 is crazy.
I don't know how you do
this every night, you know?
-Yeah, but we don't have to
write scripts
that connect to the next day
and characters.
I mean, and we -- Because we
can't get ahead of it,
because it's about --
You know, so --
Still, thank you, though,
for saying that.
-Do you do any drugs?
I've been trying --
-Do I do any drugs?
Thank you for asking.
No one asks.
-I want to know what
everyone's secret is.
I'm like, "Does anyone have
different time?"
-Hey, my -- The last thing
I want to ask.
I know your mom is a teacher,
and that must make the show
extra special for her.
Did -- She's on the East Coast.
Did you get to talk to her
the night of the Emmys?
-I did. I called her when
I could, you know,
come up for air, and it was
about 12:00 her time.
And she was super-proud,
but what was sweeter
was how proud my dad was.
My dad doesn't watch
awards shows.
He doesn't care about anything.
He watches, like --
You know, he'll watch paint dry
before he watches
an awards show
and will genuinely find it
more interesting.
But he actually --
My sister said
he was watching the Oscars
like -- like it was the --
I'm sorry, the Emmys
like it was the Super Bowl.
Like, he watched the carpet.
He watched everything
leading up to it.
And hearing that
he was really proud of me
was perhaps the highlight
of my night.
So it was really sweet.
-Well, you all deserve it.
-Thank you.
-Thanks for being back.
I just love having you here.
You guys, that's Quinta Brunson.
Don't miss the
second-season premiere of
"Abbot Elementary" and then the
21 episodes after that.
It's Wednesdays
at 9:00 p.m. on ABC.
We'll be right back with music
from Courtney Barnett.